riesen sieg für cdu chef armin laschet
heute und natürlich für reiner haseloff
den ministerpräsidenten von
sachsen-anhalt was für ein sieg für die
cdu 36 prozent die fdp bei 24 zumindest
im hinblick auf das was man erwarten
konnte
ein wirkliches hervorragendes ergebnis
für die cdu für armin laschet und reiner
haseloff was bedeutet das für die
bundestagswahl und wie schmutzig wird
dieser wahlkampf ja darüber möchte ich
jetzt sprechen mit meinen gästen mit dem
fdp- generalsekretär volker wissing mit
der cdu legende mit der cdu legende und
einmal mit dem cdu-abgeordneten und cdu
abgeordneten mit dem cdu abgeordneten
hans georg dem kommenden cdu
abgeordneten hat es gelassen und mit der
cdu legende wolfgang bosbach
schönen guten abend ich möchte anfangen
mit dem herr maßen was reiner haseloff
gerade eben über sie gesagt hat
geschätzt wird der grünen hat gerade
gesagt armin laschet müsse jetzt ihrem
beispiel folgen und zum beispiel klare
kante gegen herrn maßen zeigen das war
seine aussage da gab es gestern einen
umstrittenen schmid gegen annalena
baerbock
copsa basta damit hat er sozusagen die
namens beispiele beschrieben wie
schwierig sind die personen die in
ostdeutschland in für die cdu bei der
bundestagswahl antreten
na gut die person die ich kenne die in
ostdeutschland schwierige personen
darstellen
die kommen alle aus am besten diese
diskussion müssen wir vielleicht mal
gesamtdeutsch führen dann sowohl die fdp
ist im westen gegründet worden als auch
alle führungspositionen und auch diese
personen die sie jetzt genannt haben auf
der auf dem ticket der cdu ist nicht bei
uns sozialisiert worden
ich würde es mal in dieser deutlichkeit
zu sagen erwarten sie haben da gestern
für massive aufregung gesorgt mit diesem
tweet als ich den gesehen habe dachte
ich was will er uns jetzt damit wieder
sagen was ist das für eine
verschwörungstheorie es geht um den
tweet den sie dort abgesetzt haben über
annalena baerbock
sie haben die initialen des
vollständigen namens anna lena charlotte
alma berbalk acab genannt und gefragt ob
damit vielleicht cops are bastards
gemeint sein könnten also alle
polizisten sind basterds was hat sie auf
die idee gebracht
aus meiner sicht so etwas zu formulieren
dafür lieber herr und dass mir die
gelegenheit geben dazu etwas zu sagen
obwohl das vielleicht worte abend nicht
der passende blick ist weil ich zunächst
einmal gratulieren möchte uns
parteifreunden in magdeburg sachsen
anhalt und vor allem der
ministerpräsident für einen history und
kann man fast sagen erfolg da frag ich
etwas dazu ist die in letzten wochen
immer wieder schiffe unter geld worden
wenn ich dies oder das hat man mir
unterstellt ich würde sich antisemitisch
äußern ich würde mich gegenüber neussern
ich würde dies oder jenes mit einer
teilweise wirklich verfänglichen
formulierung meinen oder wollen und mit
trinken
gestern abend habe ich so gut wie
blödsinn anderen leuten irgendwelche
schöpfer oder geheimcode zu unterstellen
selbst sein dass alles in hinte mein
freund ich möchte deutlich machen wie
das war ironie mit blick darauf dass mir
permanent schiff oder geheimcodes und
werden
wenn ich zum beispiel ist wort global
wende unterstellt man mir ich würde mich
damit antisemitischen kurz die ihn was
völliger unsinn
und deswegen habe ich gestern haben weil
ich gesehen habe dass passt wie habe ich
gesagt dieser abkürzung kann man genau
im sinn ich auch als schiffsverkehr aber
dermaßen sie haben das ja nicht
aufgeklärt sie haben das so stehen
lassen und nutze jetzt die gelegenheit
das aufzuklären und sie sprechen die
vorwürfe an die gegen sie erhoben wurden
sie haben wir magazin cato das hängt mit
der jungen freiheit zusammen vor
wirtschaftsjournalisten bewahren zitat
deren ziele seien globale profite
zunehmend auf einige tausend familien zu
konzentrieren die sich daran machen bald
alles zu besitzen wenn meinen sie denn
mit so etwas konkret schauen sie mal
dieser artikel war ja in einer
amerikanisch seite von der stanford
university licht worden catterfeld fand
diesen beitrag wohl hoffentlich so gut
dass sie ins deutsche übersetzt hatten
und dann auch in deutschland publizieren
was ich damit und meinen mitautor sagen
wollte wir müssen uns gedanken darüber
machen in welche richtung sich uns
wirtschaft auch nun unsere gesellschaft
entwickelt und ich glaube es ist offen
wenn man beiträge in davos anschaut von
von einigen personen die dort treten das
offensichtlich gleichwohl ziele verfolgt
werden unsere gesellschaftsordnung zu
verändern unter dem stichwort der großen
transformation aber das klingt doch nach
einer weltverschwörung dass das wahnsinn
das ist nach einer reise jährige völker
schauen sie mal das ist völlig und
schaue mir nur die reden in davos an
und wenn in davos gesagt wird wir müssen
hier cupid lag in europa und der welt
nutzt eine transformation an das ist
keine verschwörung dass eine tatsache
sie können sich diese videos anschauen
und darüber müssen uns gedanken machen
und es ist ich sag mal das sind lügner
dieser diese diskussion wenn gesagt wird
es gibt keine derartige große formation
oder kein great reset ich bin der
auffassung wenn in davos öffentlich
diskutiert werden was auch
in deutschland tun und uns die frage
stellen wollen wir das und wie das aber
welche familien meinen sie denn wenn sie
das sagen
deren ziel sei es globale profite
zunehmend auf einige tausend familien zu
konnte konzentriert wen meinen sie denn
damit konkret also in diesem artikel
angesprochen dass es offensichtlich
personen in bei wall street in silicon
valley gibt große probleme mit der frage
demokratie haben ich bin ein verfechter
der freiheit demokratie
ich möchte nicht dort sehr sehr sehr
reiche personen die freiheit nicht
demokratie aushebeln das sehe ich als
mann
das sehe ich als ein problem an nachdem
ich mir einige reden wo es angehört ich
will ihnen einmal ein video zeigen auch
in die runde das video des präsidenten
des thüringer landesamt für
verfassungsschutz von stephan kramer
kontraste am dritten sechster bei herrn
maßen wenn man die summe aller dinge
zusammen nimmt auch auf den
unterschiedlichen sozialen plattformen
aber auch in eigenen reden
da gibt es eigentlich nichts
entlastendes mehr zu merken dass er
nutzt antisemitische stereotype um auf
stimmenfang zu gehen und ich glaube als
solches muss man es auch einfach
bezeichnen harte vorwürfe der herr
kramer war auch mal war auch mal beim
zentralrat der juden generalsekretär
daher kam aber auch einmal ein leitwolf
gewesen oder stand den red bulls nach
einer rechtsextremistischen russischen
motorrad gängen die am 9 mai grenze in
treptow am denkmal niederlegt der
offensichtlich auch beziehungen hat
zumindest wenn man halt er eigentlich
die verfassungsschutzpräsident werden
dürfen und dieser mann bei bis vor
wenigen oder vor zehn tagen weil noch
kandidat der spd in thüringen als eine
art konkurrent von wesen und wie meine
freunde heim und sohn und auch andere
leute heute gesagt da muss er abgesetzt
werden und dem nur anschließen er ist
charakterlich und fachlich ungeeignet
wie michael heym und warum heute
gespielt haben
herr bewegen wenn sie das hören was herr
maßen hier sagt auch auf die vorwürfe
gegen ihn und vor allem im hinblick auf
das auf was am wochenende über annalena
baerbock getwittert wurde sollte
offenbar wenn ich sie richtig verstanden
habe herr maßen eine art ironischer
tweet sein herr wissing
nehmen sie das wahr wie schmutzig wird
hier gerade wahlkampf betrieben
ich habe den eindruck dass hier über
themen gesprochen wird die mit den
problemen unseres landes wenig zu tun
haben und mit der lebensrealität der
menschen wenig zu tun haben und das
finde ich ein bisschen merkwürdig ich
glaube die herausforderung der letzten
monate waren andere als irgendwelche
abkürzungen in namen rein zu
interpretieren die menschen haben sehr
gelitten unter dieser pandemie und ich
finde wer politik gestalten möchte
sollte nicht dermaßen an der an der
einen alltagsprobleme der menschen
vorbei reden und offensichtlich
beschäftigt herr maßen sich mit völlig
anderen dingen als sie mehr der
bevölkerung in unserem land herr bosbach
wie haben sie die diskussion über
anmaßen wahrgenommen und wir haben sie
wahrgenommen was da am wochenende mit
dem berbalk tweet mit dem angriff
passiert ist
also das muss man alles nacheinander
sortieren das ganze hat ja begonnen mit
der sendung anne will mit luisa neubauer
da hat sie herrn maßen in einem angriff
auf herrn laschet unterstellt
antisemitische stereotypen zu bedienen
dann ist sie nach belegen gefragt wurden
dann kam nichts mehr dann hat frau will
gesagt dann müssen wir uns damals um
kümmern
das habe ich als etwas merkwürdig
empfinden denn man hätte ja auch mal
frau neubau in der sendung nach belegen
fragen können und nicht die redaktion
wird sich jetzt darum bemühen das zu
verifizieren oder zu falsifizieren ist
auch schade dass dann herrn maßen selber
nicht dabei sondern dass er sich gar
nicht erklären kann dass die eine
abteilung der abteilung ist entwickler
fand dem nicht originell ich es nicht
gemacht ich fand es nicht gut dass er
ironisch gemeint war das war mir von
anfang an klar
aber ich bin jetzt fast 50 jahre da
breimann erster wahlkampf war 1972 und
ich weiß man es gibt heute nicht darum
was man tatsächlich besagt oder gemeint
hat es geht im kern darum was man daraus
machen kann und dermaßen ist ja nun
wirklich und profis also der hätte doch
wissen müssen dass das ärger gibt auf
unverständnis stößt oder dass das
zumindest erklärungsbedürftig ist also
was er hier in der sendung gesagt hat
ich glaube da wird viel luft raus wenn
er das in zwei drei sätzen erklärend
hinzu gefügt hätte dass er sich darüber
ärgert dass eben immer dinge unterstellt
werden die er tatsächlich nicht mein
oder vertritt kann ich verstehen aber so
ist das nun mal wenn man sich im
politischen meinungskampf begibt dann
muss man damit rechnen dass es solche
gegenwehr gibt ansonsten kann ich nur
herrn wissing voll zustimmen
ist es eigentlich das womit wir uns als
politiker beschäftigen was die menschen
wirklich bewegt in ihrem alltag und
verhalten wir uns so dass die menschen
draußen das gefühl haben die wissen wie
es uns geht und was wir von der politik
erwarten und da habe ich manchmal meine
zweifel
welche die noch einmal zeigen was markus
blume der csu generalsekretär
zu der diskussion gesagt also ich habe
mit transfermaßnahmen eine schwierigkeit
nicht empfinden tatsächlich als
belastung im wahlkampf weil er die
koordinaten auch immer ein bisschen
verunklart im umgang mit der afg es nur
eines richtig ganz klare abgrenzung wir
haben das in bayern auch schon bei der
landtagswahl gemerkt ich habe vor
längerer zeit mal gesagt du kannst ein
stinktier nicht über stinken vermaßen
sie sind eine belastung für den
wahlkampf wird der csu generalsekretär
ich nehme es natürlich nicht so wahr ich
glaube und das hat auch glaube ich heute
die wahl im osten gezeigt das herz der
meisten leute schlägt nicht links
sondern rechts
sie möchten gerne ein etwas
konservativer politik haben ob in
magdeburg oder in berlin und ich treffe
in südthüringen in dem wahlkreis in dem
ich jetzt dann trete regelmäßig auf
menschen die mir sagen schade dass es
nicht schon vorher so war dass wir
jemanden hatten der realistische
konservative und liberale position
vertreten hat dann hätten wir früher
schon cdu gewählt
ich habe ich teile die einschätzung von
herrn böhme ausdrücklich nicht um ich
glaube er sollte sich vielleicht auch im
osten deutschlands unter die menschen
mischen und mit den menschen reden über
deren probleme und da stimme ich ein
bisschen zu wissen sagte vorher
wir sollen uns wirklich mit den
problemen die deutschland hat oder wo
ich sage die südthüringen hat
beschäftigen und das tue ich auch und
dann stellt man fest dass gerade auch
typen gebraucht werden die profil haben
die ecken und kanten haben und ich finde
die cdu hat in den letzten 15 jahren
sehr viel an ecken und kanten an profil
verloren
ich möchte ich noch einmal zeigen was
der cdu generalsekretär paul sie mehr
zum thema gesagt hat wie fanden sie
persönlich den tweet von herrn maßen
gestern über die grüne spitzenkandidatin
an den anna-lena werbung
ich glaube dazu braucht man nichts mehr
zu sagen
dazu ist glaube ich auch in twitter so
weit ich das gesehen habe dass
entsprechend kommentiert war
respekt dermaßen ist eine wichtige frage
für deutschland also die dieser tweet
ist unmöglich und täglich das ist auch
nicht unser niveau nicht mein niveau
also auch in generalsekretär ist wütend
auf sie vermaßen sie bringen da momentan
alle gegen sich auf hoffen war ja ich
glaube ich nicht ich denke ich bin
wirklich keine so wichtige person für
deutschland ich glaube herr laschet ist
in erster linie wichtige person für die
cdu und für die firma jetzt im wahlkampf
nicht unterstütze ihn so gut ich kann
der medizin falls in meinem wahlkreis
erfolgreich sein wird wenn wir uns
anschauen was heute passiert ist in
sachsen anhalt der wahlsieg der cdu und
der ministerpräsident haseloff hat das
geschafft mit einem klaren
abgrenzungskurs von der af de herr maßen
und in der vergangenheit haben sie sich
immer wieder so geäußert dass man das
gefühl zumindest haben konnte dass sie
ist nicht vollständig ablehnen eine
mögliche zusammenarbeit mit der afg in
der zukunft zu verbringen wie sehen sie
das heute ja auf welche aussagen von mir
beziehen sie sich muss ich sie fragen
ich habe immer wieder schon
gebetsmühlenhaft besagt es gibt keine
zusammenarbeit mit der afd
und ich bestätige auch immer wieder den
beschluss der cdu deutschlands das ist
keine zusammenarbeit mit der fdp und der
linken gibt woher nehmen sie das dass
ich mich nicht abgegrenzt habe es gibt
immer wieder kritik an ihnen sowohl aus
dem adenauer haus ist wird darauf
verwiesen was sie unter anderem nach dem
wahlsieg von hand kemmerich gesagt haben
der ja nun mit unterstützung eben der
afg ins amt gekommen ist und da haben
sie von einem riesenerfolg gesprochen
zum beispiel das war nicht nur ich
gewesen ich glaube auch herr rütter team
gratuliert und auch andere armin
gratuliert aber es ist das hat nichts
mit der afg zu tun und wer mir etwas
vorwirft dass ich mit der afg angeblich
packte oder zusammenarbeit will das ist
unser politischer konkurrent unser
gegner das ist rot-rot-grün und vom
adenauer haus habe ich bisher immer nur
die aussage gehört wir wünschen von
herrn maßen dass er sich gegenüber der
afg abgrenzt und das habe ich wiederholt
gesagt
es gibt keine zusammenarbeit mit der afd
aber etwas anderes ist wichtig wir
müssen der afg die wähler wegnehmen
dafür trete ich in südthüringen auch an
ich möchte dass die menschen begreifen
die asd ist eine radikale partei aber
die sorgen dieser bürger die werden auch
ernst genommen von der cdu jedenfalls
von der cdu die kunden in südthüringen
vertrete und wir werden auch diese
diesen menschen zu hören und uns um
deren probleme kümmern und sie nicht
belehren und auch nicht ihnen sagen wir
möchten bestimmte politische ideologien
durchsetzen wie es grünen macht wies
roth macht und wie steve macht ebersbach
ist das der richtige weg den daher maßen
geht um sozusagen die wähler
zurückzugewinnen von der afd
oder geht das genau in die falsche
richtung nein das ist notwendig ist
beides die klare abgrenzung bekannte
zusammenarbeit keine koalition auch
nicht den eindruck erwecken als sei so
etwas möglich für die union nicht heute
nicht morgen nicht übermorgen in libyen
gestartet sind wir mit den hinweis wenn
man das einmal sagt muss es eigentlich
reichen denn die afb ist keine
konservative partei dass eine
reaktionäre partei nichts spricht gegen
patriotismus das sind keine patriot das
sind nationalisten dass das ist das
gegenteil von dem was wir ein
wertefundament nennen
die kann man mich als wertkonservativ
bezeichnet deswegen kann es auch keine
form der zusammenarbeit geben punkt muss
man auch nicht jeden tag erklären
aber wir müssen uns schon auch als union
die frage stellen warum gibt es menschen
die ihrer partei die stimme geben da
werden stamm rechtsradikale darunter
seien rechtsextremisten die man so
fürchte dich nicht mehr für die
politische mitte zurückgewinnen kann
da wird auf protestwähler geben und da
müssen wir uns schon mühe machen
zu analysieren mit welchen gründen und
mit welchen motiven bekommt ihr afd
stimmen und wen können wir davon in das
demokratische spektrum zurück und anders
formuliert alle einfach abschreiben die
sind sowieso für die politische mitte
verloren wer mir etwas zu schlicht
herr wissing wenn sie hören wie herr
maßen dort wähler zurückgewinnen will
aus ihrer sicht als fdp nehmen sie ihm
ab dass er nicht mit der afg eine
zusammenarbeit möchte und dass dort
niemand in der cdu sozusagen im ost mal
überspitzt formuliert mit der fdp
zusammenarbeiten will
er hat es ja klar gesagt und ich habe
keinen grund herrn maßen jetzt die
irgendeine unwahrheit zu unterstellen
aber ich glaube dass das nicht der
richtige weg ist solche diskussionen
innerhalb der cdu zu führen ich glaube
der richtige weg um menschen für eine
politik der demokratischen mitte zu
gewinnen ist dass man ihnen inhaltliche
angebote macht mich treibt um dass die
schulen nicht richtig in gang gekommen
sind in den letzten monaten nicht treibt
treibt die bildungschancen von kindern
um mich treibt um teilhabe von menschen
im ländlichen raum
mich treibt um der
transformationsprozess unserer industrie
die frage wie können die arbeitsplätze
gesichert werden der die ganzen
klimaschutzkonzepte die große
veränderung mit sich bringen mich treibt
die frage um wie können wir mehr in
forschung entwicklung investieren
wie können wir digitalisierung in
deutschland voranbringen wie sie es gibt
so viel zu tun für die politik ich finde
diese selbstbeschäftigung die cdu muss
irgendwann mal entscheiden was sie sein
will eine eher sozialdemokratische
partei oder eine wertkonservative partei
aber ich finde sowas hilft ja der
öffentlichkeit nicht weiter das muss man
dann schon intern klären und dann mit
einem angebot auf die wählerinnen und
wähler zu gehen man steht mir nicht zu
der cdu ratschläge zu erteilen
aber jedenfalls für die freien
demokraten kann ich sagen uns kommt es
auf inhalte an und nicht auf
selbstbeschäftigung oder auch die frage
wie wie andere parteien sicher
aufstellen ich glaube die zeiten sind zu
ernst die aufgaben sind zu groß um
solche parteiinternen debatten zu führen
sie haben parteiinterne debatten aber
dennoch schauen sie auf die cdu als
möglicher koalitionspartner nach einer
bundestagswahl jetzt heute bei dem
ergebnis könnte es in sachsen anhalt auf
eine deutschland
koalition hinauslaufen also die cdu
zusammen mit der spd und ihnen wäre das
auch etwas für den bund also die fdp ist
bereit in regierungsverantwortung zu
übernehmen wir sehen ja wie wichtig es
ist dass eine partei die die soziale
marktwirtschaft verteidigt und die auch
freiheit und grundrechte verteidigt wie
wichtig eine solche partei ist und in
letzten monate hat ja auch viele
menschen verdeutlicht also ohne einen
einen freiheitlichen politikansatz wird
unser land sich nicht gut entwickeln
deswegen stehen wir bereit für
regierungsverantwortung sowohl in
sachsen anhalt als auch im bund und
selbstverständlich können wir
zusammenarbeiten mit der union und auch
den sozialdemokraten
ich halte das für möglich aber man kann
so was natürlich auch wiederum nur an
inhalten festmachen aber wenn sich das
anschaut wir können wir über inhalte
sprechen herr wissen also wir stellen
uns vor da gibt es eine möglichkeit
einer jamaika koalition oder einer
deutschland koalition oder einer
ampelkoalition
was wären denn das liebste das liebsten
wäre mir wenn wir uns auf ein programm
einigen können dass nicht deutschland
hin zur staatswirtschaft entwickelt das
was die grünen vorschlagen oder auch die
sozialdemokraten steuern kräftig erhöhen
und dann das geld wieder zurück
verteilen nach staatlichen plänen das
überzeugt mich nicht ich bin der meinung
dass wir dringend investitionen in
forschung und entwicklung brauchen aber
freiheitlich entschieden und nicht durch
staatliche planvorgabe also lieber eine
deutschland koalition weil die wir dann
ohne die grünen also es gibt in der
union ja einen marktwirtschaftlichen
flügel den mann ansprechen kann und der
glaube ich auch eine wichtige rolle
spielen kann alleine der wahl passiv die
letzten jahre deswegen hat sich das ja
so entwickelt wie es sich entwickelt hat
der jetzt muss die modernisierung
deutschlands in den vordergrund gestellt
werden und das muss nach
marktwirtschaftlichen prinzipien
passieren sonst kommen wir nicht voran
wer so viel vorhat wie deutschland der
kann auf die effizienz der
wettbewerbsstruktur der marktwirtschaft
jetzt nicht verzichten und das ist aber
überhaupt jetzt mal butter bei die
fische ich will ja über den koalition
welche von denen finden sie persönlich
an
sie hatte gesagt sie haben gerade schon
gesagt dass es vielleicht interessanter
wäre für sie eine koalition ohne die
grünen
das wäre dann ja eine deutschland
koalition oder herrn sammer ich denke
gar nicht in koalitionen vor der wahl
sondern ich denke ihnen das glaube ich
nicht
doch das können sie mir glauben und das
ist auch so ich hab immer wieder daran
erinnert wir gehen ja auch ohne
koalitionsaussage in die wahl
die parteien der demokratischen mitte
sie müssen miteinander bündnisfähig sein
wir können nicht das land den rechten
und linken rändern überlassen
und deswegen müssen wir bündnis wie ich
sein aber bündnis taff ehrlichen
selbstzweck sein das muss um inhalte
gehen und schauen sie die wählerinnen
und wähler müssen die jeweilige stärke
der parteien bei der bundestagswahl
bestimmen und danach wird man schauen
was kann zusammen funktionieren aber da
wird werden inhalte ganz zentrale rolle
spielen und ich glaube die fdp hat
deutlich gemacht dass regieren um jeden
preis dass das dass ein land nicht
voranbringt andererseits sehen wir jetzt
auch dass eine regierung mit uns eine
deutliche verbesserung wäre zum status
quo rosbacher aus ihrer sicht wenn eine
koalition möglich wäre eine deutschland
koalition sowie die jetzt möglicherweise
und sachsen-anhalt gebildet wird wäre
das auch was für den bund
herr uns hier so viel wie ich weiß war
heute nicht bundestagswahl sondern heute
weil die landtagswahlen in
sachsen-anhalt bis zur bundestagswahl
sind noch dreieinhalb monate
das macht doch keinen sinn dreieinhalb
monate vor einer wahl darüber zu
spekulieren welche koalitionen
dreieinhalb monate nach dem heutigen tag
möglicherweise gebildet werden können
koalitionen kommen zustande wenn es
rechnerisch reicht also eine
mathematische mehrheit ist und ein
politik hinreichendes maß an
übereinstimmung zwischen den
koalitionspartnern dass man sagen kann
das hält vier jahre und dann ist eine
guter zukunftsentwurf wir lösen die
aktuellen probleme die wir haben
betrifft für die richtigen
entscheidungen für die zukunft dann
kommt eine
koalition zustande dass rechnerisch und
das politische wenn beides zusammenpasst
und da sind ja gerade schon die
richtigen stichworte gefallen ich will
nur mal zwei nennen
wohlstand für alle schaffen wir das
durch umverteilung durch höhere steuern
durch mehrbelastung von bestimmten
gruppen in der bevölkerung durch neue
steuerarten oder erhöhung von
steuersätze wenn mit mal so dass linke
ein modell oder dass er unsere
auffassung wohlstand für alle
durch fleiß durch fleißige
arbeitnehmerin durch gleiche fleißiger
arbeitgeber durch innovationskraft durch
exportstärke klimaschutz
wie erreichen wir die ambitionierten
klimaschutzziele mit gebote verbote oder
mit innovation mit neuen technologien
das sind ganz unterschiedliche
politikansätze und da glaube ich dass
union und fdp sich näher sind als union
mit anderen parteien aber ob es dafür
rechnerisch reicht vertreten die partei
sich gemeinsam an dann treten sie
gegeneinander an und im wahlkampf machen
wir doch keine koalitions programme
sondern wir machen liberale programme
oder unions programme und dann wird
gewählt und damit gezählt und dann
gucken wir wer kommt sich politiker und
reicht es rechnerisch für eine mehrheit
im parlament verpassen
wenn wir uns die situation in sachsen
anhalt anschauen aber auch in thüringen
wird anschauen dass die afb dort immer
noch ein sehr starkes ergebnis hingelegt
hat bei rund 24 prozent was bedeutet
dass warum ist aus ihrer sicht die afd
insbesondere in ostdeutschland so stark
was erleben sie dort wenn sie jetzt in
ihrem wahlkreis unterwegs sind
also ich erlebe dort sehr viel frust und
sehr viel enttäuschung über die politik
nur die politik in der jeweiligen
landeshauptstadt auch die politik in
berlin dass die leute mir sagen wir
möchten nicht mehr dass jemand aus
berlin oder air funktion zukommt und
erklärt warum etwas nicht geht oder dass
das so da anders gemacht werden soll
das wollen wir nicht sagen wir wollen
dass das so gemacht wird wie wir uns das
vorstellen wir sind uns
89 nicht auf die straße gegangen damit
man uns wieder sagt was wir zu tun haben
steckt ein sehr tiefer frust bei den
menschen auf das meinen wir haben wir
dann wären wer den wlan etwas sagt von
wo man sie die kann ein nicht die
kanzlerin politik generell aber auch
medien im allgemeinen
sie sind sehr selbstbewusst die menschen
und ich verstehe auch dass sie
selbstbewusst sind sie haben 30 jahre
nach der wiedervereinigung unglaubliches
in der zeit geschaffen wenn sich die
orte die straßen
die landschaften da anschauen und auch
die firmen sie haben sehr viel
geschaffen sind stolz darauf und sie
nehmen daraus auch das recht für sich in
anspruch wir haben unseren teil selbst
aufgebaut unseren teil des landes selbst
aufgebaut und wir wollen für uns
entscheiden und sie sind enttäuscht
intern enttäuscht über unsere cdu und
sie sind enttäuscht auch über die
anderen parteien es betrifft nicht nur
die cdu sondern auch die anderen
parteien das nicht das gemacht wird wie
sie es sich vorstellen ich erlebe dass
gerade in suhl wo eine
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung besteht und wo
es der erste name auf einrichtung heraus
straftaten begangen werden und der
zuständige landesjustizminister sagt
eigentlich kann man da nichts machen er
redet mit den menschen oder schickt
bedienstete doch hin und mit den mit den
menschen zu reden aber nein diese leute
wollen dass es aufhört und sie haben
auch denke ich ein gutes recht darauf
das verlangen zu können
ich glaube der konflikt zwischen ich
sage mal politik und der bevölkerung im
osten besteht zu einem guten teil darin
dass man nicht auf die menschen hört und
ich glaube das was haseloff dort gemacht
haben ist gerade das er hört er bietet
ihnen auch lösungen an und sagt wenn es
nicht geht wie es besser gehen kann und
so verstehe ich sollte es auch politik
bei uns machen
ich möchte ihnen einmal zeigen was
verschiedene wähler in sachsen-anhalt
und seinen kollegen gesagt haben auf die
frage warum sie die fdp cdu
das sieht man doch dass laschet und alle
anderen im grunde die gleiche politik
fußgänger die gleiche für uns alle
natürlich politik
ich habe vor langer zeit die grünen
gewählt weil ich total für umwelt und
naturschutz bin das jetzt da verkauft
wird das kann ich halt nicht mehr wählen
warum wählen sie jetzt aber stehen die
afg heute das programm das die cdu vor
20 jahren hatte weil das die einzige
oppositionspartei ist die war habe ich
deutschland
ich würde mal vermuten die viel haben
wie haben sie vorher cdu gewählt
ist das richtig na ja und warum würden
sie jetzt auf denen sie nicht mehr die
cdu
eben weil ich diese parteien als
extremistische parteien ansehe
alle die heute hier morgen da haben wir
irgendwann mal nicht aufgegeben alle
machen eine einheit die man bisher nicht
[Musik]
herr bosbach wenn sie das hören dass da
ein fd wieder sagt die ard hat jetzt das
programm das die cdu vor 20 jahren hatte
ist da was dran nein das ist schon
deshalb nichts dran war die afg gerade
übrigens gegen den wunsch von herrn
morton beschlossen hat aus der
europäischen union auszutreten
das ist das gegenteil von dem was die
union immer vertreten hat wir sind die
europapartei schöne grüße nach sachsen
anhalt und die neuen bundesländer die
wiedervereinigung hätten wir in der
kürze der zeit und zu diesem zeitpunkt
unter helmut kohl gar nicht erreichen
können wenn wir nicht hilft zuvor den
europäischen einigungsprozess gehabt
hätten wenn wir nicht das vertrauen der
europäischen partner zurück gewonnen
hätten
in ein neues demokratisches deutschland
es war auch keineswegs alle restlos
begeistern über die deutsche
wiedervereinigung margaret thatcher hat
das anders gesehen als die allermeisten
aber wir hatten das vertrauen der
europäischen passen und eingebettet in
die gemeinschaft der europäischen union
haben wir das vertrauen gewonnen
und das hat dann letztendlich dazu
geführt dass in schneller zeit die
deutsche wiedervereinigung was damals
hoch umstritten war unter beibehaltung
der nato-mitgliedschaft erreicht werden
konnte dass exakt das gegenteil von dem
was der herr gerade im film gesagt herr
maßen uns anschauen
das zumindest in sachsen anhalt jetzt
die unterstützung für die ady leicht
heruntergegangen ist insbesondere auch
vor dem ende das umfragen noch vor
wenigen tagen etwas ganz anderes gesagt
haben aber auch im vergleich vor vier
jahren hilft ist der cdu dass kanzlerin
angela merkel nicht noch einmal antritt
vor allem im osten
ich glaube im osten besteht in teilen
eine große enttäuschung über die politik
in den letzten jahren und die nicht
einmal die sehnsucht nach einem
personellen neuanfang ist doch sehr groß
auch wenn manche sagten armin laschet
ist vielleicht nicht der beste kandidat
aber ich glaube
sehr sehr viele menschen haben jetzt
einfach die chance nach einem neuanfang
personellen neuanfang gesehen einem auch
personell nicht weiter so und ich glaube
dass doch der cdu im osten deutschlands
durchaus helfen und wird dieser
neuanfang aus ihrer sicht die ft weiter
schwächen
ich glaube und das hatte ich vorhin
schon mal versucht deutlich zu machen
dass ein sehr großer teil der afg wähler
nicht überzeugt sind von der afg politik
oder den forderungen der afd
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass ein
nennenswerter teil zum beispiel ein deck
sie den austritt aus der eu wollen
sondern dass in protestwähler das sind
enttäuschte oder verleitete leute die
wirklich meinen in der ard eine alte cdu
zu sehen und was wir glaube ich können
werden ist diesen menschen im osten zu
verdeutlichen jetzt mit dem personellen
neuanfang und wenn wir ich sage mal ein
gutes christdemokratisches programm
auflegen wahlprogramm auflegen diese
leute wieder an die cdu zu binden
zumindest in teilen zu binden und damit
ja auf die zu schwächen
er wollte wenn sie über diesen neuanfang
nachdenken der jetzt passiert mit einem
neuen kandidaten waren sie überrascht
dass die cdu in sachsen-anhalt doch so
gut abschneidet auch dort dieses jahr
das ami laschet der falsche kandidat sei
dass markus söders machen sollte auch
sie persönlich hatten sich für markus
söder ausgesprochen sind sie überrascht
wie gut jetzt zumindest diese
landtagswahl in sachsen angelaufen ist
also mit zwei dingen hatte ich nicht
gerechnet nämlich weit über 36 prozent
das ist ein großartiges ergebnis also
damit hatte ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
gerechnet und auch nicht es war ja immer
auch von journalisten von demoskopen von
einem kopf-an-kopf-rennen die rede
zwischen union und fdp hat die cdu über
60 prozent stimmen mehr bekommen als die
afd
gott sei dank also der vorsprung da hat
mich auch überrascht mit zwei dingen
habe ich gerechnet nämlich erstens dass
die union mit abstand stärkste
politische kraft wird übrigens ihr davon
aus dass wird bei der bundestagswahl
auch so sein könnte ich jetzt erklären
reicht die zeit nicht für und dass die
erfahrungen von rheinland pfalz und von
baden württemberg gezeigt haben dort wo
wir starke führungspersönlichkeiten an
der spitze haben mit vorrang mit herrn
kretschmann die populär sind viel
populärer als ihre mitbewerber
orientieren sich natürlich auch viele am
spitzenkandidaten am regierungschef das
erklärt die guten wahlergebnisse für die
grünen in baden württemberg für die spd
in rheinland-pfalz und heute hat es mal
der union geholfen weil eine haseloff
wirklich unangefochtener
spitzenpolitiker in sachsen anhalt ist
alle anderen liegen in der präferenz
weit hinter ihm zurück und er macht das
mit großer souveräner gelassenheit mit
einer ganz klaren politik er hat aus
diesem land wirklich etwas gemacht und
deswegen ist es heute in erster linie
sein erfolg aber es hilft auf der ganzen
union erwägen ob sie da sich die fdp wie
können sie es schaffen bei der
bundestagswahl auch wähler
zurückzugewinnen die von ihnen zur fdp
gegangen sind denn da waren auch einige
dabei
wir haben einen klaren kurs wir haben
ein hoch attraktives programm wir haben
einen hervorragenden spitzenkandidaten
mit christian lindner der einen seriösen
kompetenten und konstruktiven ton pflegt
das tut unserer gesellschaft gut und das
spricht viele wählerinnen und wähler an
klar in der sache aber konstruktiv und
seriös und ich glaube das ist in diesen
schwierigen zeiten genau das richtige
das erklärte aus meiner sicht auch warum
die freien demokraten so zu legen in den
letzten monaten warum wir deutlich
zweistellige oben
frage ergebnisse haben und eine
politische kraft sind mit der man
rechnet und ich bin sicher wir werden
diesen kurs beibehalten und ich denke
viele wählerinnen und wähler suchen
jetzt auch stabilität eine partei die
klar sagt wir stehen zu dem was unser
land auch in der vergangenheit großen
stark gemacht hat soziale
marktwirtschaft mit einem verlässlichen
sozialstaat aber eben auch einer politik
die immer wieder daran erinnert dass
alles was der staat ausgibt vorher
erwirtschaftet werden muss eine politik
die daran erinnert dass forschung und
entwicklung nicht in den parlamenten nun
den amtsstuben stattfinden kann sondern
in den laboratorien der unternehmen und
dass man eben auch gewisse freiräume
braucht auch investitionsmöglichkeiten
was hätte denn deutschland davon gehabt
wenn man die firma biotec höher
besteuert hätte und wir dann ein paar
monate länger auf den impfstoff hätten
warten müssen weil die nicht genügend
geld gehabt hätten für forschung und
entwicklung
es wäre teurer geworden weil der lock
down so ziemlich die teuerste maßnahme
überhaupt war
wir können dankbar sein er wird sich
immer wieder warum sich bevor sie das
gesamte fdp wahlprogramm mit vorlesen
einmal ganz kurz meint wie tim der heute
show von heute der zeigt dass nicht alle
so begeistert sind von ihnen oft brachte
heißt es die fdp ist nach zehn jahren
zurück in sachsen anhalt wie die wölfe
aber bedrohlich nur für arme menschen
wie gehen sie mit so einem angriff um
also zunächst einmal ist das
offensichtlich satire und in einer
freien gesellschaft muss so was
selbstverständlich erlaubt sein auch
toleriert werden
in der sache finde ich es geschmacklos
weil solche wolf zitate in deutschland
historisch mehr als vorbelastet sind
unser es ist nicht wirklich gelungen ich
kann jedenfalls nicht drüber lachen und
vielleicht wenn diejenige die das
gemacht haben noch mal drüber nachdenken
und drüber nachdenken vor allen dingen
aus welcher politischen ecke die wolf
zitate stammen
dann sollte man beim nächsten mal solche
mensch tier vergleiche besser lassen
ich finde das war ein griff daneben
wenngleich ich ja tolerant bin gegenüber
satirikern herr maßen wir haben ja am
anfang der sendung über ihren tweet an
annalena baerbock gesprochen da haben
sie gesagt das war ironie da müssen sie
ja eigentlich über solche tweets der
heute show auch lachen können
oder also ich bin ein humorvoller mensch
ich komme aus dem rheinland wo humor
gepflegt wird ich weiß dass in anderen
teilen deutschlands man weniger
verständnis für humor hat den humor
nicht als [ __ ] wahrnimmt also ich hätte
keine probleme mit einer mit einem
derartigen tweet ich habe allerdings
probleme wenn der öffentlich rechtliche
rundfunk der zur ausgewogenheit
verpflichtet ist sich insbesondere immer
wieder über bürgerliche politiker lustig
macht aber die grünen und die linken
hegt und pflegt das ist so mein eindruck
da würde ich gerne auch den öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk ermutigen etwas
mehr witz und humor und satire über grün
und links zu schütten
ist das auch ihr eindruck wissen also
ich wenn ich jetzt heute richtig gesehen
aber hat die heute show auch satire über
andere politische parteien betrieben die
war allerdings etwas humorvoller als die
wolf geschichte die wie gesagt ich nicht
sehr geglückt finde ich finde generell
wir sollten auch über politik mal lachen
können aber wie gesagt an der stelle
fand ich dass wolf zitat geschmacklos
können sie über solche dinge lachen herr
bosbach wie nehmen sie da die politische
auseinandersetzung auf der einen seite
war auf der anderen seite aber auch die
mediale berichterstattung
also ich habe schon besseres von der
heute-show gelesen gesehen und gehört
ich fand es nicht besonders lustig also
ich komme jetzt nicht wie anmaßen vom
niederrhein sondern vom mittelrhein aber
hier wird auch der humor gepflegt ich
habe auch immer ein bisschen mit
augenzwinkern politik gemacht denn ohne
humor hältst du's 49 jahre in der
politik gar nicht aus aber in einem
punkt stimme ich herrn mas und
ausdrücklich zu wenn hans georg maßen
mit der mit seinem lebenslauf so für
probleme hätte wie annalena baerbock mit
ihrem lebenslauf
dann würde er in ganz anderer weise
durch den kakao gezogen als die
spitzenkandidatin der grünen
das ist nun mal wirklich wahr dass man
doch doch eine ganz andere beobachtung
hat des grünen spitzenpersonal oder des
linken spitzenpersonal als in der union
oder beispielsweise in der fdp
das ist darüber kann ich mich jetzt
nicht mehr aufregen weil das schon seit
jahrzehnten so ist aber dass die
messlatte nicht immer die gleiche ist
das ist so sie spielen darauf an was
unter anderem an diesem wochenende
enthüllt worden ist bei annalena
baerbock bei der eintragung auf ihrer
homepage da geht es um die
mitgliedschaften in unterschiedlichen
verbänden und vereinigungen fanden sie
das denn tatsächlich so gravierend da
muss man aber ich finde es schon
erstaunlich dass jemand probleme hat das
so zu sortieren dass wir jetzt eine
endfassung haben bei der man auch
bleiben kann
natürlich ist das kein thema von bild
bewegen der bedeutung aber da wird da
bin ich nicht der einzige sein der sich
die frage gestellt wenn frau baerbock
schon mit ihrem lebenslauf mit der
mitgliedschaft in vereinen verbänden
oder mit ihrer akademischen laufbahn so
große probleme hat das unfallfreie
niederzuschreiben dass es in der
richtigkeit keine zweifel gibt wie
beherrscht sie denn dann die probleme
die das land hat und wie löst sie die
zukunftsaufgaben erklären uns auch für
legitim erklärt dieses mal der bus bahn
will das normalerweise läuft in so
wahlkampf da muss es doch eigentlich
mitarbeiter geben die so war es doppelt
und dreifach prüfen
gerade wenn man da eine kandidatur
bekanntgibt haben sie sich darüber
gewundert über das was da passiert ist
was heißt er hier mitarbeiter also den
lebenslauf muss man schon selber
unfallfrei zu papier bringen können
dafür muss ich ja keine mitarbeiter
haben die mich beraten oder beschissen
aber die könnten die kritik ging ja
dahin gehen dass das sozusagen nicht
entsprechend aktualisiert war dass es
niemanden gab sozusagen der verschiedene
dinge auch hinterfragt hat und das ist
da offenbar auch an einem
professionellen team fehlt das sowas
funktioniert nie die schuld auf
mitarbeiter schieben die verantwortung
trägt man selber wenn andere einen
fehler gemacht haben dann kann man das
ohne kamera mit denen besprechen und
ohne dass die medien dabei sind aber es
war auch bei mir immer so ich bin ich
nie auf den gedanken gekommen wenn etwas
schiefgelaufen ist es bei den
mitarbeitern abzuladen
dass meine verantwortung er villiger wie
halten sie das
was dabei annalena baerbock diskutiert
wir da gab es verschiedene berichte in
den vergangenen zwei wochen bereits
unter anderem eben am wochenende eine
erneute korrektur die auch bekannt
gegeben wurde von der grünen
pressestelle ist das etwas wo man sagen
muss dass wir zum wahlkampfthema rief
die bürger die bürger wollen ja wissen
ist eine person authentisch und wie geht
sie mit diesen dingen um und das ist
schon aufgefallen dass die der
korrekturbedarf jedenfalls um die
ehefrau berbalk etwas häufig zu tage
getreten ist insofern glaube ich hätte
sie selber gut daran die dinge mal zu
erklären dann viele fragen sich warum
schreibt man sein lebenslauf um wenn man
sich auf den weg macht spitzenkandidatin
zu sein wenn wir uns sie sprechen es an
die spitzenkandidatin und die beiden
anderen spitzenkandidaten anschauen
stand jetzt herr bosbach wir sehen olaf
scholz der in der beliebtheit weit oben
ist heute gab es eine umfrage die zeigt
dass er sozusagen in der direkten frage
immer weiter nach oben gestiegen ist
aber seine partei hat auch heute erneut
katastrophale ergebnis eingefahren armin
laschet ist in den persönlichen werten
nicht großartig gestiegen eher mittelmaß
mal auf platz 2 oder auf platz 3 der
direkten konkurrenten und annalena
baerbock verliert stetig wenn sie sich
die drei anschauen wer hat da welche
chancen aus ihrer sicht tatsächlich ins
kanzleramt zu kommen natürlich ist ihre
präferenz bei armin laschet aber wenn
sie die stärken und schwächen der
anderen beiden beurteilen wie spannend
wird dieser wahlkampf sein wie sie sind
pro kopf denn dass ich als mitglied der
cdu für meinen spitzenkandidaten bin das
ist das ist doch völlig klar olaf stolz
ist ein gestandener bundesminister ein
erfahrener politiker
aber das waren andere die an der spitze
der spd gestanden vor ihm auch ich hab
sie doch alle erlebt und gekannt ob das
jetzt peer steinbrück war oder andere am
ende entscheidet dann die performance
der spd und die spd hat schon vor vielen
jahren und das gilt nicht nur für die
hartz-reformen sich von ihrer
eigentlichen kernwählerschaft abgewandt
ohne den verlust dort an anderer stelle
kompensieren zu können
das heißt im moment würde auch olaf
scholz in bestform der spd nicht helfen
wer glaubt auch selber nicht daran dass
ein bundeskanzler wird natürlich braucht
so eine große stolze partei 155
geschichte einen spitzenkandidaten aber
erholt was wäre wenn sie das sagen wenn
sie das sagen dass er selbst nicht daran
glaubt dann können wir noch mal die
frage stellen glauben sie ja hofft dann
auch so was wie eine deutschlandkarte
zum glauben sie die spd wäre bereit
nochmals als juniorpartner in eine
koalition zu gehen
das ist das ist eine gute frage da ist
der spd in der vergangenheit nicht
geholfen hat bin ich mir nicht sicher ob
sich nicht die andere fraktion der erst
durch bundespräsident steinmeier
animiert werden musste in die koalition
einzutreten macht ihm die fdp aus dem
jamaica bemühen und ausgestiegen war
nicht doch durchsetzen kann also ich
mache jetzt mal die kevin kühnert
fraktion halte ich für durchaus möglich
hängt sicherlich man im wahlergebnis der
spd ab ansonsten die frage noch zuende
zu beantworten je länger der wahlkampf
dauer wird das ist jedenfalls meine
hoffnung desto mehr wird es um
sachfragen gehen um kompetenz um
erfahrung und dann mache ich mir um die
union und armee laschet keine großen
sorgen nicht ob das wohl stärkste kraft
werden und natürlich wir treten seit
sich zum ersten mal ohne amtsbonus an
die karten werden neu gemischt das sind
und deswegen sie in den nächsten
dreieinhalb monate auch noch so spannend
und ich hoffe dass wir im wahlkampf bei
aller dramatik oberhalb der gürtellinie
bleiben aber gehörte linie ein gutes
stichwort herr maßen können sie hier
versprechen dass sie in dem wahlkampf
oberhalb der gürtellinie bleiben oder
zucht in esther so oft in den händen im
smartphone um einen tweet ironisch oder
nicht dann doch los zu schicken und
damit annalena baerbock zu attackieren
aber herr ronzheimer ich bin immer noch
beamter wenn auch im ruhestand und
werden natürlich die spielregeln
einhalten und das ist auch einer
freiheitlichen demokratie ganz ganz
wichtig und ich habe einfach sorge dass
andere es nicht tun und wenn ich ins
ausland schauen und dann diese ist ja
mal diese furchtbaren attacken bei der
us wahl gesehen habe von beiden seiten
ich möchte so etwas das nicht in
deutschland also eher dass so etwas
nicht in deutschland stattfindet aber
auch nur beeindruckend wie in richtung
annalena baerbock hat schon ein bisschen
trumps züge gehabt insbesondere der
zweite twitter nach wo sie besonders
stolz waren über die page impressions
ich glaube dann haben wir auch vorliegen
da haben sie dann geantwortet danke für
das großartige feedback auf meinen tweet
777 1000 impressions innerhalb weniger
stunden ich habe einen nerv getroffen
gerne mehr so ein schritt ist ein
richtiger honeypot für grün linken
hetzer wieder über 100 blog hier danke
liebe genossen für eure hilfe
also ich sag mal so richtig ironisch
also er ist nicht nur das ist nicht
ironisch wenn man ständig als nazi
bezeichnet wird wenn mir der tod
gewünscht wird im übrigen auch von einem
journalisten der ard des wdr der mir als
philo semiten den tod gewünscht hat
wissen sie das geht auch an den nerv
wenn ich dann jeden tag und ich weiß das
sind immer die gleichen typen die keine
verlor haben immer wieder hass und hetze
auf meinem account lesen muss und es
gibt nicht nur herr ronzheimer rechten
hass oder rechtsextrem hass und hetze so
es gibt auch den aus der anderen
richtung aber das ist bei ihnen bleiben
bei dem beispiel
was ich angesprochen habe weil sie hier
ganz am anfang der sendung gesagt haben
mensch das war alles ironisch gemeint
und eigentlich nur eine antwort auf das
was auch mal mir vorgeworfen wurde
dieser zweite tweet der klingt jetzt so
ein bisschen so als seien sie da
ziemlich stolz darauf wie gut gelaufen
ist und wenn man sich anschauen wie vor
allem dieser tweet aus ihrer babbel sage
ich mal aufgenommen wurde
da haben den auch weniger mit ironie
verstanden schauen sie mal herr
ronzheimer wenn man tausende von tweets
bekommt in denen man einem der tod
gewünscht wird in denen alles mögliche
gewünscht wird und die sehe ich dann ist
es für mich natürlich ein leichtes diese
leute und das habe ich mit oli bott
beschrieben diese leute dann weg zu
drücken und zu blockieren damit sie
nicht immer wieder mir diese sachen
schicken auch per e mail über twitter im
übrigen schicken und ihn so weit war es
durchaus aber noch antworten meine frage
ja nicht herr maßen sie sagen am anfang
dass sein irgendeiner form ironisch
gemeint wie gewesen jetzt habe ich ihnen
den zweiten tweet gezeigt da sind sie
stolz auf die impressions auf 4 777 1000
also herr ronzheimer lassen uns doch
einfach mal einen punkt machen ich habe
gesagt es war ein ironischer tweet
gewesen was am kap angehen und es ist
überhaupt das zweite auch es ist verlass
nämlich das doch zu ende führen es ist
überhaupt nicht ironisch ist ist
verdammt verdammt ernst wenn man
permanent an gehetzt wird und das habe
ich mit dem zweiten tweet gemeint wenn
ich permanent an gehetzt werde dann ist
es gut wenn ich diese leute bauen blog
bei einem derartigen tweet erwische und
als als wie twitter als kommentatoren
und sie blocken kann das ist sehr sehr
ernst gemeint und das ist das was ich
dazu zu sagen habe und zum abschluss zu
dem thema herr maßen werden sie
weiterhin so hart im twitter wahlkampf
sein und gegen frau berbalk schießen und
gegen andere schießen oder haben sie
vorsichtig so ein bisschen
zurückzuhalten
als er wollte einmal ich bin ich halt im
wahlkampf ich möchte wie es vorhin auch
bosbach gesagt hat einen sachlichen
wahlkampf führen und ich bitte auch die
politischen gegner das zu tun
einen sachlichen wahlkampf zu führen
aber was ich für notwendig halte ist
dass wir auch profil zeigen dass wir
durchaus auch ecken und kanten zeigen
dass erwarten die wähler was ist denn
nun der unterschied zwischen einer cdu
und den grünen
ich bin bereit das zu markieren und dort
durch zu machen und ihn so weit wird es
auch auseinandersetzungen auf sachlicher
ebene mit unseren politischen gegner
geben sollte armin laschet gerade was
den osten angeht so ein bisschen mehr so
sein wie sie und ein bisschen
provokanter auftreten ein bisschen
härter und vielleicht da auch ein
bisschen schärfer loslegen was würden
sie armin laschet raten wir im
bundestagswahlkampf aus deutsche wähler
gewinnen kann
also ich glaube nicht dass er mich
braucht als berater hat genügend berater
im konrad adenauer haus und auch in
düsseldorf ich glaube armin laschet wird
sich richtig und ordentlich aus seiner
sicht aufstellen
ich führe mein wahlkampf für
südthüringen weil ich das ziel haben das
direktmandat zu erreichen ich bin nicht
ich möchte nicht auf der landesliste
stehen sollen ich möchte die leute in
südthüringen überzeugen dass ich der
richtige vertreter bin und wenn ich es
schaffe ist es gut dann haben die
südthüringer eine deutliche eine laute
eine starke stimme in berlin die die
interessen südthüringens wahrnimmt wenn
nicht dann eben nicht aber mich
interessiert weil sie jetzt ja dort eben
auch sind in ihrem wahlkreis und ihren
wahlkampf machen was werden die die
rezepte aus ihrer sicht die ein
kanzlerkandidat laschet mitnehmen sollte
was sind die themen mit denen die cdu
dort dann auch ein wahlkampf gewinnen
kann aus ihrer sicht ich glaube ein ganz
ganz wichtiger punkt ist einfach zu
begreifen dass wir in deutschland ein
weiteres auseinandergehen zwischen stadt
und land einfach nicht mehr hinnehmen
dürfen ich war auch sehr froh muss ich
sagen jedenfalls aus heutiger sicht auch
seehofer im bundesinnenministerium mit
der abteilung heimat einer abteilung
geschaffen hatte
die für den ländlichen raum zuständig
ist ich glaube es fehlt in berlin und in
den anderen hauptstädten landes
hauptstädten fehlt einfach zu sehr das
bewusstsein dass politische entscheidung
die für berlin die für köln oder für
andere großstädte in deutschland gut
sind vielleicht verheerende folgen haben
können für das land wenn ich
beispielsweise die politik bei der
energiewende sehe und die ich in meinem
wahlkreis wahrnehme dass es
für eine familie mit zwei kindern nahezu
unmöglich ist ohne zwei autos zu leben
zu fahren zur arbeit zu gehen zum arzt
zu fahren und so weiter und nur um das
als beispiel zu nehmen ich glaube wir
brauchen um auf in ostdeutschland wo es
nicht viele große städte gibt wo die
meisten menschen auf dem land leben sie
wohl schön aber sie haben ganz andere
bedürfnisse als die in der stadt
brauchen wir politiker brauchen wir mehr
verständnis in der politik für die
bitter besonderen bedürfnisse der
menschen die auf dem land leben
herr wissing wir haben jetzt über die
chancen und möglichkeiten von armin
laschet gesprochen über das was olaf
scholz erreichen kann wenn man sich ihre
werte anschaut dann nähern sie sich da
ja olaf scholz tatsächlich an eine
umfrage hat sie sogar schon gleich
aufgezeigt in der letzten woche haben
sie schon mal intern drüber nachgedacht
naja vielleicht schicken wir doch noch
einen kanzlerkandidaten ins rennen also
bestand sind wir uns aber zunächst aber
wenn ich hier maßen höre muss ich sagen
es ist konsequent dass er nicht auf
einer landesliste der cdu antritt denn
erfordert ja ständig dass die cdu sich
von ihrer eigenen politik verabschiedet
ist also das ist schon bemerkenswert
weshalb dann trotzdem als cdu
direktkandidat antritt wundert mich aber
zu ihrer frage also natürlich sehen wir
dass es die volksparteien quasi auf
bundesebene erodieren das auch nicht
verwunderlich die union hat eine partei
rechts von ihr zugelassen die spd eine
partei links von ihr zugelassen damit
haben sie ihre kernaufgaben als
volksparteien vernachlässigt aber wissen
sie wir wählen die im september kein
bundeskanzler sondern einen deutschen
bundestag
und dieses kanzlerkandidaten modell ist
aus der zeit gefallen das passt nicht
wir müssen auf die inhalte jetzt uns
fokussieren und ein zunächst einmal das
parlament wählen
der bundeskanzler oder die
bundeskanzlerin die wird dann später vom
deutschen bundestag gewählt und nicht
unmittelbar im september und deswegen
finde ich dass diese formate nicht gut
sind aber man muss natürlich in der tat
die frage stellen wenn die parteien in
den umfragen gleich sind oder etwa
gleich sind weshalb die einen
zu bestimmten fernsehrunden eingeladen
werden und die anderen nicht ich glaube
das ist eine sackgasse in dem man sich
da hinein begeben hat weil man immer
wieder diese kanzlerkandidatenfrage mit
der bundestagswahl frage zu stark
vermischt
sie sagen man für mich die frage zu sehr
herr bosbach wenn wir jetzt auf die
nächsten monate schauen und sie haben
gesagt dass die themen eine rolle
spielen werden die entscheidenden
sachfragen eine rolle spielen werden wir
haben hier wo ich gerade sitze in der
letzten woche annalena baerbock erlebt
die grüne spitzenkandidatin die grüne
kanzlerkandidatin und die hat bekräftigt
dass der spritpreis unter den grünen
teurer werden so 16 cent das hat danach
fast eine woche die debatte bestimmt um
den benzinpreis ist es gefährlich für
die grünen dass sie sich klarer äußern
zu möglichen preiserhöhungen und die cdu
zwar was das klima angeht ähnliches will
man sich das programm anschaut dass da
erarbeitet wurde mit andreas jung aber
eben nicht so klar preise benennt also
wie gefährlich wird das aus ihrer sicht
für die grünen also wieder die grünen
haben ja leidvoller erfahrung mit dem
thema benzinpreis richtig
benzinpreiserhöhung muss man fair
bleiben durch die co2 bepreisung des
kraftstoffes ist der kraftstoff ja noch
tor schon teurer geworden jahresbeginn
die grünen erleben jetzt etwas was sie
schon öfter erlebt haben sobald es
konkret wird und die menschen exakt
merken welche auswirkungen das für sie
hat dann kommen sie ins grübeln
um mal das beispiel ländlicher raum
aufzugreifen
es ist ein unterschied ob ich in einer
großstadt wie berlin lebe mit einem
ausgefeilten öffentlichen
personennahverkehr
das erste was meine tochter gemacht hat
als sie zum studium nach berlin ging ihr
auto stillgelegt weil sie es nicht mehr
brauchte sieht im ländlichen raum ganz
anders aus da kann ich den menschen
nicht mal eben zu rufen erfahren sie mit
der bahn wenn keine bahn fährt ich hab
nichts gegen flug taxis
eine tolle erfindung aber ich komme in
region sind die menschen vor wenn
regelmäßig der bus kommt die masten
nicht ausflug hat sich also muss ich
doch gucken wie mache ich die
ökologische wende auf sozial verträglich
wenn es dann leute gibt die überhaupt
nicht betroffen sind die andere aber
massiv da gibt es eine schieflage und
darüber müssen wir im rat spricht es ist
das thema was am ende annalena baerbock
eine mögliche kanzlerschaft kostet weil
wenn man sich die umfragen anschaut gibt
sie jetzt runter davor war sie vor armin
laschet nein es ist nicht das thema es
ist eine konkretisierung des slim des
themas klimawandel klimapolitik ich
glaube das sage ich jetzt wehren wissen
mit als vertreter ohne vertretungsmacht
wir setzen eher auf innovation wir
setzen auf technologie auch oft die
technologieführerschaft des high-tech
und forschungsstandortes bundesrepublik
deutschland und wir wissen dass es einen
untrennbaren zusammenhang gibt zwischen
der wirtschaftlichen leistungsfähigkeit
des landes und der sozialen
leistungsfähigkeit wirtschaftliche
stärke wettbewerbsfähigkeit
innovationskraft das sind die richtigen
stichworte um die aufgaben solide
finanzieren zu können vor denen wir
stehen und da ist die digitalisierung ja
nur ein beispiel
er will sich zum abschluss unserer
sendung würde ich gerne von ihnen wissen
was für ein tweet würden sie über die
diskussion heute verfassen
also ich würde sagen spannend wie die
union den weg zu sich selbst sucht ich
bin gespannt was dabei rauskommt herr
bosbach hätten sie nicht in der wiesent
provokanten sie gesagt warum weiß ich ob
ich nicht bei twitter unterwegs bin und
mich zu den twitter aber sie können ja
gut formulieren also den wir an sie
wären bei twitter was was würden sie
formulieren
ich hoffe dass der ganze wahlkampf so
lebendig wird wie unsere diskussionen
heute abend herr maßen die frage
natürlich auch an sie und sie sind ja
offenbar der twitter meister der
provokation also was wir tun also
ronzheimer ich provoziere nicht immer
und ich will auch nicht mal provozieren
man muss hier gelingt sich auch mal
loben und ich muss sagen
ronzheimer sie haben mich heute zwar
etwas ich sage mal deutlich angenommen
aber ich würde mir wünschen eine
derartige ausgewogene diskussion wie wir
sie heute abend geführt haben auch mal
im öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehen zu
erleben
und da bin ich ihnen dankbar dass sie
mich heute abend eingeladen haben
herzlichen dank das war die richtigen
fragen für heute abend mit volker
wissing die fdp generalsekretär cdu
legende muss man sagen wolfgang bosbach
und hans-georg massen
cdu-bundestagskandidat herzlichen dank
und alle weiteren infos noch von der
wahl und dem was dort kommen könnte
finden sie natürlich auf bild de und
bild live gibt es wieder morgen um 11
uhr